I don't see how we're ever gonna find a
house it's no there's got to be one of
the creepiest closets in the country I'm
all for like a fixer-upper but it's a
falling apart over the last two years
we've been looking at a bunch of
different open houses but now we have a
baby on the way so it's serious we
partnered with realtor come to give you
guys a three-part series that's all
about our process of trying to find a
house last week we saw a four million
dollar dream house but this week it's
time to get serious
we're gonna have to start actually
thinking about the houses that we can
legitimately afford so we're gonna have
to make some compromises figure out
what's a want and what's a need I think
that we need some help all right so we
were searching for homes on realtor.com
but maybe we should find a realtor
what about Kenya specializes in our
neighborhoods it seems like she knows
the market we can start with the basics
we know you need room for your baby do
you want okay that is the difference
between a need and a want write down the
ten things you absolutely must have so
let's compare our two lists why don't
you read yours off and I'll tell you if
it's on mine backyard check okay Circle
that two bathrooms check okay good close
to work I know I have indoor/outdoor
flow that's important to me
sports temple hey Gerry I also put safe
I didn't think of that I'll add safe
view nope okay pool okay we're looking
for two bathrooms at least two bedrooms
a backyard space for entertaining a safe
walkable neighborhood and a master
bedroom it feels like a sanctuary I feel
like that's a really solid list a solid
list and our wants are close to work but
also extra bedrooms and then
a big tree we've got the realtor calm a
pup 3-bed 2bath okay seems like kind of
a busy street though okay like my
beautiful window yeah looks out on on
the freeway the living room flows right
into the diner oh yeah it's got such a
good like party flow and I don't mind
this I think this is kind of okay kind
of okay just what I've always wanted
I don't know if you noticed this but
it's sure peed No yeah stop it this is a
nice big very spacious room plenty of
space for a nursery here most nurseries
don't have a door to the outside I feel
like people steal babies it's not just
something moving or is that just areas
that mean that's real
on to the master bedroom it's got a big
bathroom still got sharpies like a
little kitchenette in the master bedroom
so like I'm brushing my teeth here
you're brushing your teeth no I don't
want to do that well let's check out
this backyard it's awesome
okay so beam is going to need Sybase
outside when you envision your yard is
it a sprawling yard do you have
indigenous plants do you have stones
this is lovely
yes grass a little seating area enough
half fence to meet neighbors was on our
want list a lot to like about this house
there's a lot to like about this house
so what'd you think
pros mm-hmm two bathrooms pretty close
to your work squarely within the range
we said that we wanted the master
bedroom to be like a sanctuary it's like
a bomb shelter really cons the baby's
room opened up on to the backyard I feel
like it's not safe especially because
it's on a busy street it had that awful
start being fine we can replace that
with crayon I had a really bad commute
when we lived in Chicago was like 45
minutes to an hour I really want to try
and find a place that's a little close
to where working
I would classify that as a need if you
can afford Rhinos neighborhoods okay so
this one's a five bed two bath
whoa five bedrooms yeah let's check out
our commute time on the realtor.com app
45 minutes okay that is far this is the
kitchen
Wow like they took a car windshield you
just like slap it up here oh god it
looks almost volcanic I'm pretty serious
as paint so volcanic let's go check out
your mancave
what yeah okay yeah there's a hole this
is like a second house it even has a
second kitchen if I lived in this house
when I was like 15 oh yeah I would be
that would have lost my virginity what
can I get a Sharpie I feel like this is
this is not a Sharpie not sure yeah I
mean this whole downstairs is just like
1970s sensual vibes
[Music]
you're asking for a second kid with that
dance let's check out the upstairs okay
this one is weak compared to the one on
the busy street this view is amazing
open this up drop the diaper poop chute
I do like the double sinks though I do
like the dumbest things there's a shower
phone ring ring hello
oh yeah she's right here hey Arielle
yeah they said that you're beautiful
I think they're showering you with
compliments this is a really good sized
window too big it sets for the homeowner
who says I want a walk-in closet but I
want it full of ghosts in this market
none there's gotta be one of the
creepiest closets in the country coming
this summer
hey classic country you know I will say
this about the closet I'd like to leave
yeah I would like to get out of it we
have a full basketball court out here
also I love this like amphitheater here
and themed thank you very much ladies
and gentlemen hey hey I'm on the top of
the hill yeah still got it
so what'd you think of that one okay
pros pros this was huge
beautiful open kitchen I mean it had a
view technically had a felt like a
sanctuary so much as a cemetery so what
are the cons it is the only way we can't
afford it is cuz it's really far out
there
even a house at the maximum price we can
afford is not perfect I mean I don't see
how we're ever gonna find a house the
average buyer when they purchase their
first home they live in that home for
five to seven years it's best to buy
something that you can make your own or
buy something a little smaller than you
expected and then when you outgrow that
we do it all over again all right let's
check out Street peek here it looks like
this one is the cheapest one in the
neighborhood it's wrong with it looks
like it's already kind of falling apart
[Applause]
[Music]
you break it you buy it
these are nice you can put a bug you can
put a very thin hook on here
everything here is like they don't make
it like this anymore they literally
don't make it they literally though make
it
what if in the process of our
renovations we like put the toilet in a
weird spot and then all of a sudden
everyone's like I want this weird toilet
house it's like plummets and then the
market crashes and then okay that's a
really bad story most of the time when
you sell later down the road if you sell
you'll be selling to yourself does that
make sense
of course right got ourself five years
yes like what even is going on here like
do I have breakfast like table of one
I'm all for like a fixer-upper but this
is like this is like falling apart it's
fine it's a falling apart er well that's
why this house is is so affordable
nursery nursery
perhaps oh we have to keep this let's do
some push-ups yeah
it's our third bedroom - I think it's
this is the antechamber yeah is this
like I do not like the stairs very nice
[Music]
it's just a wall that's so big it's like
the backyard of my dreams this is gonna
have an entire middle school soccer
practice here and I don't know what this
is but I am a loving and I will say I
love this tree but it looks like is
winning the war against Bajaj not too
far away from work 3-bed 2bath super
walkable it does have one big tree down
it's in between that creepy closet and
that creepy carpet I keep feeling like
we're gonna walk into a house and be
like this is it like this is the house
of our dreams well it's funny because
whether the home is ugly or beautiful
whether it needs a little love where it
slipped it'll still sing and when it
sings you'll know okay Ariel it's
decision time exactly - yeah first we
have a busy street bum boy
the living room has lots of light I love
those floors there's a great flow it is
close to work if it's loud I can't
imagine having kids running around a
busy street the hillside homestead which
I really like we could have some major
parties there we could also have an
enormous family right house it just
start popping them out was the furthest
one from work that's true
it was on the higher end of our price
range so we really can't make a lot of
changes to it then we get to the
spanish-style fixer-upper you need own
lot more and it technically has three
bedrooms but the third bedroom is kind
of like - the second bedroom it's at the
low end of our price range right so we
have some room in our budget yeah we
could really make it
and the backyard was beautiful oh this
is the fun's this is where it gets good
what we need to do is we need to make
sure we write the strongest offer it was
just like a number it's always more than
the number there's a story that we're
going to tell you guys are qualified and
approved how you guys are amazing human
beings we can pull the baby card he
Trump's everything yes and then we're
going to package that all up and we're
gonna do our best to make sure that that
seller chooses here this assistant time
now or never I think we should put an
offer on this page style fixer I think
we should - yeah dear home owner we love
this house my wife Ariel is pregnant
with our first child and we can imagine
raising our family in your house we hope
that yeah
we'll hope that you'll accept our
generous offer and make our dreams come
true
that's a record you're not doing it
[Music]
home to the creepiest couple in the
world